welcome to this video playing Tetrarch
truck no name in them so anonymous I am
okay let's play and tried and tested
Slovaks change Eric C 1 is a move that I
looked at him recently now it was queen
bee three I guess some quite comparable
to other lines but check there is the
the rook develop and the night is not
yet on e2 is this the same thing
basically yeah it is not really rook c8
is good of course okay yeah it is the
same thing keep keep forgetting
listening but okay um we can still play
this position the night is not on f3 but
on e 2 which is set a slight difference
and Queen B 6 where is he going with
that to be 5 or okay well i will
probably have to cancel anyway look see
well now maybe I can still do something
against the slightly slightly rican
queen side
it's nothing a spectacular of course but
maybe I'm still a very very slight very
slight edge that I can try to claim yeah
I'm trying to make sure coming before
it's not coming yeah he's got 92 also i
was thinking maybe neither for something
like that but that's not really leading
to to anything yeah i can go Knight c3
but this is really just just very dry
92 I know maybe I'm just seeing ghosts I
have a tech night f4 is really not doing
anything whatsoever I don't know it's
probably not mattering very much if i go
to g3 or see 3 yeah it really is nothing
it just very equal but ok maybe maybe I
can still try something like here
getting the rook to c5 Quincy three
yeah he is getting the bishop to see
forum this is this is totally totally
equal so I have to do that basically
maybe Bishop d6 look a one
I wonder why didn't you go to be seven
okay okay so see playing for Queenie to
hear this discount to play maybe
Queenie to him it is still equal even if
he lost a move on whatever
going to play king of two to control the
square
okay that's that's a good defensive move
really okay
yeah maybe Queen to d8 if possible I got
this check time to check out mm yeah and
III hangs with checks oh yeah I have to
do that nothing nothing nothing else
rawr our third question could try to do
this on time yeah okay so he played it's
very precisely i guess with with Roxy
aid check this is this is a good way to
play here even Queen B 6 as possible
okay 92 yeah it is very very it's a very
very solid position I still wonder
yeah this is not good this is you know
what I need to do I need to do something
here like f3 this is a good move after
that it's not that not that that easy
because he does not have the 94
activation this might be a little
something really I can also use the king
now I have this controlled this is this
is maybe a slight slight something I
mean stop vicious enthusiastic like +1
for white which I don't believe really
but um why it is definitely a bit better
here yeah what I what I had not really
appreciated it so this is this kind of
idea and the snow makes life very dull I
can only initiate this trade 93 is
basically the same thing and here we we
try it around a bit but there is nothing
nothing serious happening I believe
that's very precise yeah gee I have to
take really ok ok I have to check its he
has got this big counter threat and I
don't have anything I cannot cannot do
anything against it um I have no counter
idea i can do this and this but it takes
a long time and he can easily defend
against it so i had to make the draw so
it's this whole opening is of course
very very very safe but sometimes you
can get a little something at tier with
f3 i could have gotten something so it's
a it's a bit of a shame that i didn't do
that ok thanks for watching